- Hey guys, I'm
thrilled to be sharing
this little mini
interview with you.
You probably saw the viral video
of Kory and his beautiful young
daughter Royalty this week
talking about how silly
critical race theory is
and how we should judge
people by the content
of their character and not
the color of their skin.
So I'm gonna sit down with
them in just a minute,
but in case you missed the
viral video, here you go.
- Daddy teaches you
you can be anything
in this world that
you want to be, right?
Don't daddy teach you that?
- Yeah.
And it doesn't matter if you're
Black or White or any color.
- It doesn't matter if you're
Black, White, brown, yellow.
- Yellow.
- Right?
- Black.
- And how we treat people
is based on who they are
and not what color they are.
- And if they're nice, and
if they're nice and smart.
- See, this is how this is
how children think right here.
Critical race theory
wants to end that.
Not with my children,
it's not gonna happen.
My baby's gonna know that no
matter what she wants to be
in life all she has
to do is work hard
and she can become that.
- Work hard.
Even though you don't know
anyone, you can make friends.
- (chuckles) Yeah,
you can make friends
no matter what color they are.
So we need to stop CRT,
period, point blank.
Children do not see
skin color, man.
They love everybody.
If they're good
people, they love 'em.
(warm instrumental music)
- All right, I am with
Kory and Royalty right now.
And Royalty, I gotta
talk to you first.
Can you believe that
you're an internet star?
Can you believe it?
And I guess how's that
lollipop more importantly?
- Tell him.
Tell him, he's asking
you how's the lollipop?
- How's that lollipop?
- Good.
- Lollipop's good?
- Yes.
- All right, we'll let her
get sugared up a little bit.
Kory, I mean, you put that
thing out there on TikTok.
Did you have any idea
what was about to happen?
- You know, I had no clue.
Baby no, stand up over here.
I had no clue,
man, it was crazy.
Like, I posted it and then
like two weeks went by
and then other people
started posting it
and all of a sudden
it just blew up
and I'm just so grateful and
thankful that people shared it.
You know, I'm
appreciative and yeah.
- Royalty, how old are you?
- Six.
- Six years old.
Is that kindergarten,
is that first grade?
- First grade.
And your dad seems like he's
a pretty good teacher, huh?
- Yes.
- Kory, when did you wake
up to all of this stuff?
'Cause I think most people
watching the video were like,
yeah, that's the truth.
Kids are kids, people are
people, but it takes a lot
for people to see
through the nonsense.
- Yeah, I've been waking
up to it for a while now.
I'll say parents have been
sending me different videos
and things and
different curriculums.
And I've been seeing different
videos on the internet.
And then my daughter had
an incident at her school
with them teaching
her about segregation.
You know, you want to tell him?
- After you.
- Okay.
Thy were teaching
her about segregation
and like, White-only water
fountains and things like that.
And I had to actually address
the principal about it.
So yeah, it's been
going on for awhile.
- What kind of
pushback did you get
when you talked
to the principal?
- It wasn't really any pushback.
He just told me that the teacher
didn't really run it by him.
She just played the video.
- Right, Royalty, how do
you like being in school?
Are you back in school?
Are you in school right now?
- Yes, well, I mean, no.
- She just had her last day.
- Oh, you just
had your last day?
- I'm on summer break.
- Oh, very nice.
What are you going
to do for the summer?
- Go swimming and ride my bike.
- Pretty good.
That's a good
summer right there.
Kory, what about just like
within your family and friends,
like just as a father
talking about this stuff,
do you get pushback or
are people with you?
Are people kind of
quietly supporting you?
- Actually, that's
funny you say that
because I just got a call
yesterday from a family member
I hadn't spoke to in at
least a couple years.
And he was pretty upset.
He was pretty angry
that I was pushing back
against critical race theory
and just how I push back
against systematic racism
and all those different
types of things, too
and BLM and all of that.
So yeah, you know, it's mixed
in the family, but as far
as people that text me or DM
me, I would say it's all love.
- Yeah, what do you do normally?
So you're a content creator.
Is that on the side?
Is that a full-time?
- No, that's full-time, yes.
- Oh, that's full-time,
that's awesome.
So tell the people more
about what you're doing.
- Yeah, I'm just trying to
spread the message, man.
I got my clothing
line right here.
I do it with my cousin.
GODLYVIBEZ is the website.
And yeah man, we're just
trying to wake people up.
That's what the
mission is about.
I actually have
done other videos.
This was just a video I did
with my daughter on
critical race theory.
But yeah, I've been pushing back
against the mainstream media
and things like that
for a while now.
- Yeah, Royalty, you like
doing videos with your dad?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, what's
your favorite part
about doing videos with Him?
- Being with him.
- Being.
That's that's a good daughter
and a good father right there.
What about in that message?
You were saying things that
you just want to be nice
to people and you want to be
friends with people, right?
You don't care about
that other nonsense.
- He's asking you that.
You were saying it doesn't
matter what color you are,
you want to be nice to people,
people will be
nice to you, right?
- She likes doing the
handheld, you know?
- Right, right, right.
- What else would you
want people to know?
I mean, now a lot of
eyeballs are on you.
Suddenly your name was
trending and people
were trying to
find out about you.
That video, I mean, it
really went bananas.
It's gotta be seen at least
5 million times already.
Like, what else would you
want people to know right now?
- Right, as far
as the video goes
I want to say, thank
you to everybody.
I really appreciate you
guys sharing the video.
I want people to know that we
should not look at each other
and base our relationships
with each other off of things
as superficial as
skin color or race.
You know, I think that
you love everybody
no matter what they
look like, you know?
It's who they are on the inside.
It's their character
that matters.
And that's what I was
trying to get across.
That's what we were
- Yeah, you like that message?
Do you like that
message, Royalty?
- Yeah.
We should treat everybody
how they behave,
how they act towards us.
Pretty good, right?
- Yeah.
- It's just a beautiful thing.
Well, listen,
Kory, if it's okay.
I would like to send Royalty.
You think she could do something
with maybe like
$100 Amazon card?
Is there anything she
might want to get?
Royalty, is there
anything you want?
If you had some-
- A Lamborghini!
(Dave laughing)
- I'm a YouTuber,
I'm a YouTuber!
- She has never said
that before to me ever.
Okay, you're hearing
this for the first time.
I'm hearing this
for the first time.
- A Lamborghini?
- I said it to Mommy.
- You said it to Mommy before?
Wow, okay.
- Man, I hope Mommy's
got a good job.
(Kory laughing)
Is there anything that might
be a little less expensive
than a Lamborghini that
would be pretty good?
- What's a toy you like?
He's asking, he wants
to get it for you.
- I want to get you something
- You don't know?
- American Girl doll.
- Oh, done.
All right, that's it.
You're gonna pick your
American Girl doll.
You go to the website and
I'm gonna take care of it
'cause I think you're awesome
and you're spreading a
lot of love in the world
and that's what
we need right now.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
The Lamborghini, you're
gonna have to give me
a little time on that.
- Here, give it to me, baby.
- All right, well, listen,
you guys are both
awesome, and Kory,
I'm gonna text you separately.
We'll take care of that.
And Royalty, you are just a gem.
And I look forward to seeing
what you do in the world.
- Say thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, hey, we appreciate
you man so much, thank you.
- Thank you guys, awesome.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.